ANYONE GROCERY SHOPPING LATELY
CAN'T NOTICE HOW THE PRICE FOR A
DOZEN EGGS SKYROCKETING.
WHAT'S CAUSING THE PRICE SURGE?
VANESSA YURKEVICH, HELLO!
VANESSA WHAT IS CAUSING THE
PRICE SURGE?
>> MANY AMERICANS WOULD GO TO
THE GROCERY STORE, NOT THINK
ANYTHING MUCH ABOUT BUYING A
DOZEN EGGS NOT REALLY LOOKING AT
PRICES'S CONSIDERED AND IS
CONSIDERED A STAPLE IN AMERICAN
HOUSEHOLDS.
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR A BIG
PRICE INCREASE.
IT STARTED LAST YEAR ABOUT
$1.25.
UNTO $1.75 NOW ITS $4 H.25 NOW
BECAUSE OF THE DEADLY BIRD FLU
THAT HAPPENED LAST SPRING AND
IT'S CATCHING UP TO US RIGHT
NOW.
IN ALASKA DEMAND FOR CHICKENS
AND THEIR EGGS IS HEATING UP.
>> ALREADY SOLD OUT EVEN BEFORE
THE EGG SHORTAGE.
SELLING EVERYTHING I HAD.
>> Reporter: IF THE YOU'VE BEEN
TO THE GROCERY STORE RECENTLY
YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED FEWER EGGS
AND HIGHER PRICES.
UP ABOUT 11% LAST MONTH ON
AVERAGE FROM NOVEMBER, UP NEARLY
60% IN THE LAST YEAR.
$11.49 IN NEW YORK.
$10.99 IN HAWAII.
>> RIDICULOUS.
>> Reporter: THE HIGHLY PATH
GENIC AVIAN INFLUENZA OR AVIAN
FLU IS LARGELY TO BLAME.
NEARLY 58 MILLION BIRDS AND
CLIMBING HAVE DIED ACROSS 47
STATES IN THE LAST YEAR.
A RESULT OF THE DEADLY VIRUS.
WILD BIRDS CAN CARRY THE DISEASE
AND SPREAD IT TO DOMESTIC FLOCKS
WHEN THEY MIGRATE.
>> ONE WILD BIRD COMING INTO
THEIR CHICKEN RUN AND THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW, 10 BIRDS, 20
BIRDS, 30 BIRDS JUST DROPPING
DEAD.
>> Reporter: SOME STATES
RECOMMENDING ALL POULTRY BE
MAINTAINED INDOORS.
POULTRY AND BIRD SHOWS CANCELED,
STRICTLY ENFORCED.
>> THE AVIAN BIRD FLU IS
SERIOUS.
>> Reporter: STRUGGLING WITH
PRICES ON THEIR MAIN INGREDIENT.
THE FALL MIGRATION OF FALL BIRDS
SENT AVIAN FLU CASES SPIKING
AGAIN.
>> WE GO THROUGH A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF EGGS.
THE LAST COUPLE OF EGGS JUMPED
AS HIGH AS 60%.
>> Reporter: HOW HAVE YOU BEEN
ABLE TO ABSORB THE HIGH PRICES
OF EGGS?
>> UNFORTUNATELY RAISED ALL
PRICES 10%.
>> Reporter: FOR SOME INCREASE
IS TOO MUCH.
A BREAKRY IN NEBRASKA CLOSES ITS
DOORS THIS WEEKEND.
>> I THINK ABOUT WHAT OUR FAMILY
COULD AFFORD TO PAY FOR A
COOKIE.
I TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION.
WE CAN'T CHARGE $5 A COOKIE.
>> Reporter: THE RIPPLE EFFECT
GOES BEYOND RESTAURANTS AND
BAKERIES.
TAKE A LOOK AROUND THE GROCERY
STORE.
ITEMS THAT USE EGGS LIKE
MAYONNAISE, UP 1.8% IN THE LAST
YEAR.
>> FROM THE FLU TO THE INCREASES
IN INFLATION, ALL COMBINED
TOGETHER WITH THE SHORTAGE,
PERFECT STORM.
>> DEFINITELY SEEING PRICES
SHOOT UP RECENTLY.
>> Reporter: DOES THE THAT STOP
YOU FROM MAKING THE PURCHASE?
>> NO.
NOT AT ALL.
JUST BUYING THINGS TO MAKE A
CHICKEN CUTLET AND EGGS IS THE
BASIS FOR THAT TOO.
ONE OF THE WAYS THERE'S JUST NO
WAY NOT TO PURCHASE THEM.
>> Reporter: GOOD NEWS FROM THE
U.S. DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE.
THIS WEEK THEY SAID PRICES ARE
STARTING TO FALL A LITTLE BIT,
BUT THAT SUPPLY REMAINS LIGHT TO
MODERATE, AND, YOU KNOW,
HOLIDAYS, REALLY A TIME WHEN
THERE WAS A LOT OF DEMAND FOR
EGGS.
PEOPLE WERE BAKING.
PEOPLE WERE COOKING, BUT WE'RE
THROUGH THE HOLIDAYS NOW.
SO DEMAND MAY BE JUST A LITTLE
BIT LOWER, BUT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT FUN TO GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE AND SEE EGGS COSTING ABOUT
$10.99 HERE IN NEW YORK.
HAWAII, SAME PRICE.
KEEP YOUR EYE OUT AND LOOK FOR
THOSE CHEAPER PRICES IN YOUR EGG
AISLE.
GUYS?
>> THANK YOU, VANESSA.
I SENT A PHOTO TO YOU GUYS.
IN THE GROCERY STORE THE OTHER
DAY.
$3.99, $4.99 WHICH IS HIGH BUT
NOT AS BAD AT $11 OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S HERE IN NEW YORK.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL COME DOWN.